THIS IS HUGE PROGRESS FOR THIS
BUT AS WITH ALL THINGS PROGRESS
IS INCREMENTAL.
ONE STEP FORWARD, TWO BILL
O'REILLY'S BACK.
>> THE AMERICAN PROPAGANDA
CONTINUES WITHOUT FAR LEFT
ZEALOTS TRYING TO DIVIDE
AMERICANS ALONG COLORED LINES.
>> Larry: I LOVE KNOWING WHEN
I'M GOING TO START SCREAMING AT
THE TV.
[LAUGHTER]
SO I CAN ALERT MY DOWNSTAIRS
NEIGHBORS, RIGHT.
BASICALLY MY NEIGHBORS KNOW
THERE ARE TWO TIMES WHEN THINGS
GET LOUD AT CASA WILMORE, ONE
DURING BILL O'REILLY AND THE
NEXT IS WHEN HALLE BERRY IS IN
TOWN
SOMETIMES WE WATCH O'REILLY.
ALL RIGHT, THIS BE GREAT STUFF.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
ACCORDING TO THE FBI THERE WAS 1
MILLION 163,000 VIOLENT CRIMES
IN 2013
ONLY 3,500 WERE CLASSIFIED AS
RACE-BASED HATE CRIMES.
>> Larry: ONLY 3,500? THE LAST
TIME BILL O'REILLY SAID
ONLY 3,500 IS WHEN SOMEONE ASKED
HIM
ABOUT HIS CHOLESTEROL LEVEL.
LET'S ASSUME THESE NUMBERS
ARE TRUE. EVEN THOUGH BILL IS
NOT A BIG NUMBER GUYS WHO SAID
HE WAS COVERING THE FALKLANDS
WAR BUT WAS 1,200 MILES AWAY.
OKAY, 3500.
STILL WORKS OUT TO 9.58 RACE
BASED HATE CRIMES PER DAY.
ACCORDING TO MY ANALYSIS THAT'S
ABOUT 9.58 TOO MANY.
RIGHT.
[APPLAUSE]
TOO MANY.
YES.
I AM WILLING TO CONCEDE THERE'S
.01 THAT PROBABLY DESERVES A
LITTLE BIT OF THAT.
PROBABLY SHOULDN'T SAY THAT I
DON'T KNOW.
AT LEAST BILL O'REILLY ALWAYS
HAS GUESTS ON TO TALK DOWN TO.
WHAT BROTHERS IS HE GOING TO
HAVE TO TALK ABOUT THAT.
IS IT JUAN WILLIAMS? HE'S ON THE
LEFT. HE'S NOT ANGRY ENOUGH.
YOU KNOW WHAT, MAYBE IT WILL
BE THAT BLACK LADY FROM OUT
NUMBERED.
GOT A BIT OF A 'TUDE, RIGHT.
OH NO, IT WILL BE THAT CRAZY
BLACK PREACHER TALKING ABOUT
HAVING GUNS IN CHURCH.
REMEMBER HIM.
WHICH BLACK FOX ARE YOU GOING TO
BRING OUT.
>> WITH US HERE IN NEW YORK CITY
MONICA CROWLEY.
AND KIRSTEN POWERS
>> Larry: TWO WHITE LADIES?
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A NUANCED
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS RACIAL.
OKAY, I GUESS THIS IS THE
CONVERSATION I'VE BEEN WAITING
FOR.
FOX, YOU ALWAYS SURPRISE ME
BUT NEVER DISAPPOINT ME.
ACTUALLY, TO BE FAIR, THE
CONTRIBUTOR KIRSTEN POWERS
ACTUALLY DID TRY TO BRING SOME
REASON TO THE PROCEEDINGS
>> RACISM IS A SERIOUS ISSUE
AND I DON'T KNOW WHY YOU'RE
UNABLE TO SEE THAT.
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S AN
EPIDEMIC OF RACISM IT'S NOT
INGRAINED IN THIS SOCIETY AND
EVERY COUNTRY ON EARTH HAS
RACIST ELEMENTS IN IT.
>> Larry: RACIST ELEMENTS.
WHAT'S A RACIST ELEMENT,
--NEGRONIUM?
YOU'RE GOING TO FIND TONS OF
NEGRONIUM IS SOUTH CAROLINA.
IF O'REILLY CAN'T FIND A BROTHER
TO HAVE ON HIS SHOW, I'M GOING
TO INVITE MYSELF.
PLAY THAT LAST CLIP AGAIN.
>> I DO THINK RACISM IS A
SERIOUS ISSUE IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND I DON'T KNOW WHY YOU ARE SO
UNABLE TO SEE THAT.
>> BECAUSE I DON'T THINK IT'S AN
EPIDEMIC OF RACISM, I DON'T
THINK IT'S INGRAINED IN THE
SOCIETY.
>> Larry: HOLD ON KIRSTEM, I
GOT THIS THIS TIME, OKAY.
ACTUALLY BILL, YOU'RE RIGHT.
IT'S NOT AN EPIDEMIC BECAUSE
THIS [BLEEP] HAPPENS ALL THE
TIME.
IT'S NOT A PLAGUE IT'S THE
COMMON [BLEEP] COLD.
NEXT.
>> THE WORLD IS BEING TOLD BY
ANTI-AMERICAN HATERS THAT WE ARE
RANK RACIST SOCIETY AND THAT IS
A LIE.
ALL RIGHT, YOU MONICA.
>> ARE INDIVIDUAL RACISTS SADLY
YES.
DOES INSTITUTIONAL RACISM EXIST
ANYMORE.
NO IT DOES NOT.
>> Larry: OKAY, OKAY.
FIRST OF ALL WHY IS MONICA
CROWLEY ANSWERING HER OWN
QUESTIONS, I DON'T KNOW.
DOES IT CONCERN ME ABOUT THE
STATE OF HER MENTAL HEALTH?
YES IT DOES.
I'M SAYING IT'S BAD ENOUGH
YOU HAVE THREE WHITE PEOPLE
DEBATING ABOUT RACISM. BUT THEN
TO HAVE ONE ANSWERING
HER OWN SOFTBALL RACE QUESTIONS?
>> SLAVERY THAT'S PART OF THIS
COUNTRY'S HISTORY.
>> SO WHAT?
>> SO WHAT.
>> Larry: SLAVERY GETS US SO
WHAT.
THAT ARGUES YOUR POINT WHY WE'RE
STILL DEALING WITH THIS RACIAL
PROBLEM IN AMERICA.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THE
HOLOCAUST.
WHATEVS. SLAVERY IS WHAT THE
CONFEDERATE FLAG DEBATE'S ABOUT
>> YOU'RE MISSING -- NO IT'S NOT
THE LUNATIC FRINGE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE RACIST.
RACIST.
>> Larry: WHAT KIND OF NOISE IS
THAT.
>> YOU CAN'T SEE WHAT'S
HAPPENING BECAUSE MOST AMERICANS
ARE NOT RACIST.
WE'RE NOT.
>> REALLY.
HOW MANY BLACK FRIENDS DO YOU
HAVE?
HAVE.
>> IF YOU THINK MOST AMERICANS
ARE RACISTS, I'M ASHAMED OF YOU.
[CROWD CHEERING]
>> Larry: HOW MANY BLACK
FRIENDS DO YOU HAVE AND YOU GOT
ALL MAD
I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO SAY
HERE.
IN FACT, CAN WE JUST PLAY THAT
BACK ONE MORE TIME.
PLAY THE BACK.
>> HOW MANY BLACK FRIENDS DO YOU
HAVE.
>> IF YOU THINK MOST AMERICANS
ARE RACIST, I'M AWE SHAME OF
YOU.
>> Larry: SHE ASK YOU AGAIN
AND YOU SAID THE SAME THING.
OH, MAN.
AND THEN DO YOU KNOW WHAT I SAY
TO THE FACT THAT YOU THINK
RACISM DOESN'T EXIST IN AMERICA.
SO WHAT?